welcome back to new rock stars this is
big question the show that gives you too
much information
about the logistics of wumbo size
primates
reptile warfare patrick i don't think
guambo is a real word
my name is mt and i am here today with
the always wonderful
and amazing tommy bechtold how you doing
yeah i'm doing great now after that
introduction whoa i got a pep
in my step oh my lord
i've been dying to do one of these with
you man so like it's gonna be really
cool
it's gonna be amazing it's gonna be
great but godzilla vs kong finally gave
us the showdown of the millennium with
these two
alpha titans from the monsterverse
however the fight was ultimately rudely
interrupted when a larger
more mechanized threat emerged and uh
you know postponed the fight for the
greater good
but this has all left us all wondering
who
would really win in the godzilla versus
kong
fight if it really went down tommy you
know what
the corporate media okay the people that
would advertise
no i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
as i ran into a camera uh all right
let's let's talk
about it godzilla and kong are alpha
titans
protecting earth from other evil kaiju
that want to do us
in yes their form of protection can be
somewhat destructive to our cities
not great for the real estate market
unless you're in construction
but it's hard not to wipe out a few
buildings when you're as big and as
massive as they are
just ask me when i'm walking in like a
tiny rite aid you know like when it's
like a little miniature rite aids and
i'm trying to walk through like the soap
section to get to my pepto-bismol
i kind of feel like godzilla just
marching through
big elbows everywhere exactly dude like
the world is just too small for for
bigger bigger men like us because i'm
knocking [ __ ] over all the time with
these long limbs absolutely i don't know
why god gave me these long limbs but
that's
you know what maybe he you're you were
meant to reach things for short people i
think that's what it is that's what i do
all the time um old ladies love me at
the supermarket i'm just like oh
oh you can't reach that life alert i've
got it for you my friend
they're like you're a superhero yes
all right so in the film godzilla vs
kong
it really seems like godzilla has the
upper hand on kong before being
forced to deal with mechagodzilla but
would this really be the case would kong
actually have a chance at beating
godzilla
let's break it down by looking at the
stats and fighting styles of these two
behemoths the talent
break it down tommy all right let's take
a look at some of the stats we see
during the opening credits of the film
first up it's king kong hi
standing tall at 337
feet tall they list his weight at 158
tons
he's working on it don't judge him the
holidays were rough
for everyone that's a big [ __ ] tommy
that's a big [ __ ]
he's thick however this was a stat from
the 1973 version of kong
so adjusted for inflation he weighs a
million pounds i
wash myself with a rag on a stick
since he has pretty much tripled in
height since then
we can extrapolate his current weight
and assume his proportions are the same
that would put him in at about 4 226
tons that's a lot of cheat days now
let's talk about intelligence
he's highly adaptive and resourceful he
uses tools
as we know he knows all about hand print
technology
put the hand print in the hand print uh
he's smarter than me that's for sure
strength he's immensely powerful
it will just define his strength yeah
he's just crazy he's yolked
uh durability tough and resilient great
recuperative powers
okay that's nice i'd like to have
recuperative powers for my hangovers
weaknesses susceptible to flammable
attacks and he's a weakness like all of
us
for beautiful eyes okay he can't say no
to a woman with beautiful eyes i i made
that up i
i don't know that's true godzilla let's
talk about the g
man our godzilla is an awesome godzilla
height 393 feet tall with a length of
582
feet wow damn that is very tall man that
uh yes
that is consider a crew in the nba
because that's that's that's a baller
right there that's a power forward
minimum
uh probably a center and his weight is
164
000 tons that's a significant weight
advantage if i'm
doing my math right his blood volume is
uh
530 000 gallons for those of you
that are keeping blood volume stats he's
walking so that's around
like my blood volume like 529
000 so like we're wow so you're i mean
that's good to know
if you're looking for godzilla gains you
don't have far to go uh
his walking speed is 18 miles per hour
but that's usually because he
just doesn't feel like he's in a hurry i
think i bet you he can run
i wonder what his 40 time is good
all right his tensile strength of bones
3000
mps which is a mega pascal which is a
unit of measurement
i won't even pretend to understand it's
a unit of measurement that the um
primarily use a pedro pascal as oh
perfect
yes it's a mandalorian yeah i heard uh
that's um
how the metric system is going it's
evolving to using pedro pascal
units um it's very handy tommy i i
mti would be totally fine if as a
society we move towards a pedro pascal
based like way of life that's what i've
been saying ever since season one of the
mandalorians
i was like this show is great why am i
not measuring via pascals
yeah chime in on the comments all my
pascal pals
all right don't be shy atomic breath
energy yield yes that's that
atomic ray he blasts out of his mouth
that's horrible
that's some indigestion that's 3.15
times 1014
joules 10 to the 14th power now jules
i'm not talking about those cool little
e-cigs you teens think you got figured
out
you're going to kill yourself with those
these are nuclear jewels heat measures
of heat i believe
uh and like those will kill you faster
to be honest
one way or another jules gonna get you i
guess godzilla be hitting the jewel
first and then blowing it out
[Laughter]
[Music]
that explains it that's why that's why
he always looks so cool
uh oh god that's gonna be memed ah
conclusion what can we conclude
these stats would appear to give
godzilla the advantage he's got a little
more height on kong
he's also longer and heavier godzilla
also has that atomic breath
coming from his internal nuclear power
source on the other side it's much
easier for kong to gas out
since he only all he has to do rely on
is his regular old metabolism
however let's not count out kong
completely he has a serious reach
advantage on godzilla
kong has massive long and powerful arms
meanwhile godzilla has a much weaker
shorter arms having a reach uh advantage
in fighting
in sports and mmas is a serious thing i
remember
i'm older than you there was a big fad
in the like early 2000s late 90s of
making celebrities fight each other
so there was like celebrity boxing this
is not just like a beverly hills
nightclub this was like they really
they really got into the boxing ring and
i remember uh
minute bowl the basketball player who's
like seven seven
uh was boxing i wanna say it was either
like it was like butterbean the big fat
boxer or like an nfl lineman
and i swear to god like they weighed the
same because minute bowl was so tall he
weighed like 340 pounds
they weighed the same and that dude did
not touch minute ball like he would have
been like he's gonna kill him
because he's so much heavier or like you
know he looks so much stunning minute
ball just
held his arms out was like boom boom
boom and he just exhausted him so
i mean kong might be able to exhaust
godzilla
yeah because he has that long arm reach
man he should have done it
it's all about the reach now there is a
term called ape
index in fighting and that refers to
your arm span relative to your height
this is calculated by subtracting your
height from your arm span
most humans have a neutral ratio their
arm span and height is roughly the same
but so i have a higher ape index for
example the boxer sunny liston
was 73 inches tall but had a reach of 84
inches giving him a positive 8 index of
11
inches whoa wow that's an extra 11
inches that would come in real handy
in other places yes
what about my ape index negative three i
hate being irish
it just goes inside like a scared turtle
ah
whatever i'm confronted by by titans of
course that's the only thing i'm talking
about
uh okay we also can't ignore the intake
good god
my mom watches these good we also can't
ignore it
and why and by the way mom why are you
watching this you don't care about
godzilla versus kong
stop supporting me
her other kids are like engineers and
nurses they're the ones you should be
watching me i'm a professional idiot
it's because she loves you tommy she
does i am her favorite because i'm the
nicest
all right we also can't ignore the
intangibles kong has a massive mammal
brain giving him
a huge intelligence advantage he's able
to use tools and think strategically
well godzilla's reptile brain will have
him constantly taking
the quickest most destructive attack
technique the opening credits also give
us a look at some of the previous
monsters
our two alphas have faced in the past so
let's dive into their strength of
schedule
to see what training has been done by
both champions to bring us to this
moment
let's take a look at some of kong's foes
first in the credits they list a giant
squid
skull crawlers which are now considered
tokens i guess
and a mysterious titan they don't really
make
make clear which titan this is so this
is just some other foe that he's fought
then we also have godzilla's foes we
know in the first godzilla he fought
muto
massive unidentified terrestrial
organism he also fought
ghidorah and then there were some other
monsters that that
bowed down to ghidorah and then bowed
down to godzilla
so he may have beaten them too
off-screen those include rodan
cilla behemoth methuselah and of course
the stay puft marshmallow man
they got their ass beat twice yes that's
right they did they got their asses
kicked
and former toronto mayor rob ford as
well may he rest in peace
fight godzilla the brexit show in the
credits show us more of the godzilla
side than the kong side but
it's clear that godzilla has faced the
more impressive monsters he's just got a
better
list of opponents but don't count out
kong here either
well godzilla has faced the big names
kong is putting in the reps he's got to
eat remember so he's killing skull
crawlers
in giant squids all the time on his
island if he feels like calamari he's
gotta go out there and kill a giant
squid
okay he can't just order it up and kong
usually is on his own in these fights
well godzilla has the aid of some humans
to help him win the battle so you know
let's not count him that's true
that's right it's true kong is out here
hunting his food
on his own while every time godzilla
comes up to fight somebody
the us military or whatever military is
around him is usually helping him out in
some way so
that's very true so never underestimate
the help of the helpfulness of the us
military oh my god this is an army act
enlist join the army kids
they'll take care of me probably i don't
know maybe no one's making me say that
no one is making me say that obviously
thank you to everyone who serves in the
army
i'm just saying that uh in the godzilla
movies
they may not always have the best
intentions and only in the godzilla
movies everywhere else they're totally
fine
all right godzilla and congo for more or
less three rounds in the film
so let's go to the tape to break it down
the first fight is on the open ocean
this is a total advantage for godzilla
for one he's not chained up
he can swim quite easily uh and stay
submerged for long periods of time
kong on the other hand is an oxygen
breathing mammalian type titan
big mistake shouldn't have done it big
mistake
big huge that's true he's not meant for
open water combat
he's not meant for it but that doesn't
mean he's not gonna be good at it
godzilla
should have totally won this fight but
he just backs off because he thinks kong
is dead in the water brilliant strategy
by uh both uh
alexander skarsgard and kong to just
play dead but
i don't think it's completely fair to
put this one
in the l column for kong the
circumstances were outside of his
control kong would never be out in the
open ocean on his own
obviously exactly terrible human beings
have once again
captured an animal and brought it
outside of the zone where it will most
thrive
in order to serve their selfish needs
tal is old as time
song is old as rhyme we pick animals up
that's their whole jam like kong has no
business in the middle of the ocean
zero business guess where kong would be
super happy on his
island eating pterodactyls that's what
he wants to do
he was just chilling he was minding his
own business and then the human just
came
picked his ass up and chained him on a
boat and then he got his ass kicked
exactly and you know
you know that we as humans understand we
shouldn't be doing this to animals
because i am watching
a giant computer rendered not real thing
being chained up to a boat and i'm like
this is wrong i should not do this
that's enough end this movie right now
[Music]
it's time to stop it's like you do
realize king kong's not real he could be
we don't know that seriously they were
like they were treating this man
with the most disrespect and they didn't
even tell him what was going on really
it was just
like hey and they kept him doped up so
that he wouldn't get angry come on
you wouldn't like him when he's angry
you cowards round two
this is their first battle in hong kong
godzilla has blasted down to the hollow
earth
and challenged kong to a fairer fight on
land
kong emerges from the hole hello with an
atomic radiation absorbing axe
that's big green coming into play come
on he's got
he could this is how you counter an
atomic being you get an
axe that can absorb it god i want that
axe for my house just for walking around
could
don't make me bring out the axe uh all
right kong is able
to show off his agility and speed on
land this again is a big advantage for
kong he's able to dodge a lot of attacks
and even blocks an atomic blast with the
axe which is one of my favorite scenes
in the trailer
yes dunks the energy back into
godzilla's face
i could watch that when i saw that in
the trailer i lost it i was like this
movie's gonna be so much fun
yes absolutely kong's reach also enables
him to throw some devastating punches
which godzilla can't block with those
stubby little arms he has used his tail
to block punches in past godzilla films
but i don't think he can keep up with
kong punching with both arms i mean
that's a lot of
tail strength that's right duck and
weave and not dude kong takes the win
with a knockout blow from the x
neither titan is dead but they both take
a moment to rest in their corners
like any good fight you just gotta rest
in the corner you know what i'm saying
this builds up tension you know what i'm
saying
go to your corners think about what you
did nobody puts baby in a corner i would
love if godzilla and kong both had
coaches
yes get back in there kong he's killing
you go for the ribs
don't let that bastard breathe so round
three big brain kong makes a smart move
and ambushes godzilla who's just blindly
looking for him kong goes for the choke
out but is tossed by godzilla
and that dislocates his shoulder ouch
godzilla starts to attack his chest
pins him and then roars in his face this
is a pretty
definitive devastating victory for
godzilla because had he used his atomic
breath
kong's face would have been barbecued
but
he didn't unfortunately for kong
mechagodzilla emerges now the two
frenemies
have a new foe to face together in the
end they go their separate ways but i
don't know about you
mt but it seemed to me in the end that
kong kind of like
knelt to godzilla a little bit like it
didn't seem like they were both
facing off and then kong kind of went
like they like animated him to kind of
bow to him
like not like subserviently but just to
kind of be like there's no more fighting
i think it was just more like a hey man
uh you kick my ass
i'm gonna take this l just leave me
alone listen we beat that big robot up
why don't we go kick it on our own
islands for a few weeks and then we can
get back together
figure this out somewhere maybe we'll go
to san francisco and knock that down
again so
it seems like the film makes it clear
that godzilla
was the better titan fighter but is that
really the case did kong ever really
have a fair chance
had kong shoulder not been dislocated i
don't think he would have been pinned so
easily
i'm a big kong guy like going into this
movie i've been rooting for kong like
straight up so i have a major kong bias
but yeah i really don't think that if
his shoulders
were 100 operational like my shoulders
are
i think that there would have been it
would have been a different fight i
think that it was
it's quite possible for godzilla to be
uh overtaken by konk but that's just me
and my uh
my monkey bias i could i completely
agree with you so
kong's reach agility and super
intelligence should make him a better
fighter than godzilla
yes godzilla has a nuclear core for a
heart and atomic breath but hide behind
a tall building and surprise him with a
giant axe to the face and you got
yourself
a victim so there's a universe where
kong wins this
i think the respect these two beasts
have for each other ultimately kept them
from delivering the killing blows
i think that we've established in
previous movies both of these
creatures their nature is to protect not
to destroy
and then they only destroy when
threatened so i think that once they
noticed the other one is in a vulnerable
position they would the reason they
wouldn't go
from the for the killing shot is because
they realize that neither of them are
truly evil
there were multiple times in the film
where it seemed like one could have
killed the other
but it said they backed off and lived to
fight another day so
yeah they're just they're just good
dudes like you know what we'll fight if
we
have to but like we'd rather not the
real question i need someone to answer
for me is can you explain to me how
there is light in hollow earth why is
there a sunlight
seriously where is that coming from are
those just like like
stage lighting i don't i don't get it
drop us a comment if you know
thank you for that information tommy
that was very informational
damn but we are going to dive into our
bite size questions next but
first a word from some of the folks that
help us bring
big question to you and who is our first
sponsor of the day tom
let's talk about honey baby
oh honey honey we've all seen that promo
code field
taunt us at the checkout while in
shopping online enter a code get a
discount
i don't have a code i'm not one of the
cool kids uh the only codes i had
growing up were these two hands well
thanks to honey manually searching for
coupon codes
is a thing of the past you can feel like
a cool kid too honey is the free
shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best ones
it finds right into your cart when you
check out the honey button drops down
and all you have to do is click apply
coupons wait a few seconds you impatient
bastard
as honey searches for coupons it can
find for that site
if honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the prices drop
if it doesn't find it the price will
stay still you are not having a stroke
you are just not saving money you
jabroni here
at new rockstars off-screen producer
zach is a huge honey fan
and i'm not just talking about that
golden liquid he puts on all his healthy
fruits
to keep his adonis body he loves to buy
tabletop board games nerd he can't stop
bragging about how honey saves him
10 on his recent game purchases well we
know he's not bragging about getting
laid if he's bragging about his board
game purchases so
i guess brag about one thing and not the
other i'm just kidding
zach's in a very healthy relationship i
don't want to speculate on it
honey has found it's over 17 million
members
over two billion dollars in savings
2 billion you could buy a sports
franchise for all the savings honey has
done
if you don't ever have you could do it
if you don't already have honey what is
the matter with you
you could be straight up missing out on
free savings it's literally free and
installs in a few seconds and by getting
it
you'll be doing yourself a salad and
supporting this podcast
we'd never recommend something we don't
use get honey for free
at joinhoney.com bigquestion
that's joinhoney.com slash big
question yeah tell them thomas
sent you now i don't know if you guys
know this but you don't have to be
unhappy with your smile
yeah candidates help thousands of people
with their clear
comfortable removable and practically
invisible aligners to help straighten
their teeth justin m from atlanta
georgia had this to say about candid
when i was younger i used to have a gap
in the front and on the side i noticed
that people
would always look at my mouth first so i
was looking for a fix
candid ended up being the perfect
company for me
you can't stop me from smiling now
there's no comparison your treatment is
prescribed and closely monitored
remotely
by a licensed orthodontist and you'll
have the same quality of care that
you'll get
from an in-office orthodontist but from
home
because of uh covet 19. the average
candid treatment is just six months and
you'll start seeing results
way before then and it costs thousands
less than traditional
braces so it's pretty good become your
best
you start straightening your teeth today
right now you can save
75 on candid starter kit go to
candidco.com
big question and use the code big
question that's
candid co dot com slash big question
using the code big question take
advantage of this limited time offer to
save 75
on your starter kit candidco.com
bigquestion that is code big question
all right it's time for a segment that i
love because i'm all about nibbling you
know
some people go for the big meals me no i
just eat 17 small meals a day to keep
this figure
uh it's a shake for breakfast another
shake for breakfast
five more shakes for breakfast lunch and
then 15 dinners what about 11 seasons
now here's the bite-sized question for
today can odin enchant anything he
wishes
the way he enchanted mjolnir that was
asked by
janice julius on discord janice j
u l i j s janus
i drank a lot of gin and juice and then
i took a question from janice julie
she's probably the nicest person ever
and we're just butchering her name i'm
sorry
i'm so sorry janice thank you for your
question all right go ahead that's a
great question tommy because in the mcu
we have only seen odin place an
enchantment
on one item thor's hammer mjolnir he
does this by channeling the power
of the odin force in order to cast the
spell on the mighty hammer through the
phrase
whosoever holds this hammer if he shall
be worthy
shall possess the power of thor well we
don't see him enchant
any other items before he dissolves in a
very sad scene in thor ragnarok
in the comics odin has been known to
enchant some other items
items like stormbreaker the very same
hammer we saw in avengers infinity war
and end game was originally created in
the comics for
the marvel hero beta ray bill a horse
looking man
who can hit real good with a different
hammer than thor
stormbreaker odin and chance the hammer
to give it similar worthiness properties
as mjolnir and the ability to transform
beta ray bell
into his mortal korbanite form which is
a very a versatile hammer i don't know
much hammers that can do that tommy no
not me definitely nothing by black and
decker
oh no i checked home depot i went up and
down those aisles and they were like
uh we don't know what you're talking
about please leave sir and i was like i
know the hammers here
i know it they choked me out with one of
their home depot smocks it was uh pretty
uh
crazy anyway they shouldn't have done
that to you
give me my enchanted hammer you fools
[Music]
and odin also enchants a mace called
thunderstrike with similar properties to
mjolnir
as well as allspeak which gives the
wielder the ability to speak and
understand
any language in the nine realms
including groot probably
i would love to understand groots
because i don't
i know i like to pretend that i do but i
don't i've only watched the guardians of
galaxy a million times
i appreciate you being vulnerable with
me here you know i feel safe
being able to tell you secrets too i
also don't speak groot
you know i i put it down that i did on
my resume
but um it's a lie i had to speak groot
for a uh
sonic commercial and i i they called my
bluff they saw it on my resume it was an
audition and
i just i panicked and i i ended up
speaking something far more offensive so
it was uh
it was bad i didn't get it i didn't get
it i didn't get the job see at least you
can go to baskin robbins because you
would that's
because baskin robbins always finds out
that's true you know they know that's
their slogan
baskin robbins try us and find out
they always find out like an ant-man um
i don't know what i'm saying all right
and thunder strike was used by eric
masterson a human who has merged with
thor
at some point before kicking his ass all
on his own
and another mystic warhammer enchanted
by odin was
crusher which is a really hardcore name
this holy weapon was utilized by red
norvell
four of the crimson locks again similar
properties as mjolnir but this warhammer
also can manipulate matter on a
molecular level which is
pretty dope i've got to say um that's
pretty crazy and giving the wielder the
ability to transmute
elements like like some type of
alchemist or something it's crazy
and crusher can also create wormholes
allowing the wielder
to teleport from one place to another
without the use of a
toyota prius like me
delightful and in the comics odin uses a
lot of enchanted weapons and objects
some of which
may have come to him enchanted already
but others he could have easily
enchanted himself
for his own benefit i mean he's odin and
the magic of the all-father
is all-powerful and one thing to note
but when it comes to the worthiness
enchantment on mjolnir
odin is immune so he can alter
any of the enchantments as he sees fit
oh
how convenient for him right right he's
just like hey you can't use your hammer
thor but i could use it because i can do
it
what a freaking dad rule i could use it
because i say so
like you can't have it anymore because
you're being an [ __ ] and i say so
so you're not worthy dad you're not
worthy son
[Laughter]
how about that i'm always worthy that's
right
uh all right well let's uh second
question let's stay in this world of
thor
can dr strange lift thor's hammer
using eldritch magic that's asked by
dragon fruit also on the discord
eldritch magic is the style of magic
utilized by dr
steven strange and all the masters of
the mystic arts now doctor strange is
also
the sorcerer supreme making him the most
skilled practitioner
of eldritch magic in our world and even
the ancient one foresaw that doctor
strange would be the best sorcerer
supreme
our world has ever seen ain't no one
better than doctor strange tommy
and when it comes to lifting mjolnir
only those that are worthy have the
power to physically lift it thanks to
the enchantment
placed on it by odin now there may be
some sort of levitation spell that
doctor strange could conjure up
that could move the hammer without him
physically touching it
but that wouldn't give him the power for
at all and doctor strange might also
not be able to use magic to lift the
hammer as the forces behind the hammer
come from the all-powerful odin force
which means
that it comes down to which magic is
more powerful dr strange's magic
or odin's magic and i'm gonna have to
say
odin has the my money's on odin on this
one because
he's just he's just the god he's he's a
god man he's a god figure
and the odin force is something that
doctor strange hasn't learned in his one
is one of his little
nerd library books i don't think yeah
read that in one of your books nerd
got him having fun is a little bit hard
when you have a library card that
doesn't have a library with um the odin
force it's true
um that's the arthur joke you don't have
to put it
all arthur jokes included
however after the events of infinity war
and end game where doctor strange
sacrifices his life
and the time stone to ultimately save
the universe i mean i would say that he
should probably
take another go at lifting the owner
because he did some pretty selfless
things and
in doctor strange one he died like a
zillion times to save the universe
with dormammu so you know
i know that doctor strange has a little
bit of an ego problem that he's working
on but
i would say just give give another shot
it couldn't hurt
well it's gone now i guess there's no
more hammer to lift up but
hey give it a go when it comes back
but we have reached the end of the show
which means
that it's time for the greatest segment
of all time tommy and do you know what
that segment is
[Music]
it's a box of scraps yes
and now keeping up with the theme of
godzilla vs kong
today's box of scraps question is tommy
if you got to be
the monster whisperer for any giant
kaiju
of any type which type would you choose
and
why this is you have to answer in why
such a
great question i love this i'm thinking
through my rolodex of giant
creatures and it's like there's so many
to pick from would i pick mothra to fly
through the sky
would i pick you know one of the uh
kaiju from pacific rim that were like
you know a three-headed monster or a
four-headed monster
but in the end mt there's really only
one giant creature that i want to be a
whisper for and that's clifford the big
red dog he was like oh my god
why dog's our man best friend you get
cliff for the big red dog to listen to
your every command he's bending over
he's putting you up on his head he's
walking you around the town
on the back of a giant adorable dog do
you know how many chicks you would get
if you could command clifford infinity
chicks tommy
babes eating out of the palm of your
hand
if you could control clifford the big
red dog how about you mt what do you got
damn that's a good one that's honestly a
really good
i wish i thought about that first but i
think just for like comedy's sake
i would love to see a giant kaiju sloth
yeah that would just be hilarious
he's just like hanging off of the empire
state building just being just really
chill it's
extra slow because he's like massive so
it's just like yes
[Music]
and the military's just like you won't
shoot at it it's not really doing
anybody
he's kind of cool but that's just me but
that's it for this episode of big
question thank you so much
to tommy as always for joining me on
this episode you can follow him
tommy bechtold and you can follow me
mastertainment on twitter and instagram
and all that [ __ ] and of course follow
new rockstars send us your big questions
using the hashtag
bigquestion and subscribe to the podcast
feed and give us a nice rating and
review please because
that really helps us out like it's a
huge help so please leave that
and subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube and hit that notification bell
because
you gotta know when we upload stuff
because we be uploading we we do be
uploading every day
pretty much well not every day just you
know very regularly alright thank you
guys so much for watching and uh stay
safe everybody
[Music]
you